it's free organic reach i don't know
what else to tell you
you post something and 80 000 people
might say it
this portion is like with me so i think
this is when you need to get selfish
like you need to ask your question
hiring is guessing
firing is knowing like you got to go
fast that's how you get [ __ ] done that's
when you figure stuff out
this is the television and the
television
is the radio the 40s [ __ ]
so everybody uh how how's it going so
far how's the uh
how's the day been going
great great yeah fantastic solid
great all right so why don't we go
around joe maybe you'll call on people
and what we're doing here is going kind
of in-depth consulting so
uh would love to spend one minute on you
know who you are
and you know and a little bit about
yourself um
and uh and then i'll go back around and
i want you to think about the very
direct
question you have because i want to go
very narrow
um and so it's great to see all of you
it's great to see some faces calvin it's
good to see your face again
haven't seen you in a while great to see
that nice to see you and nice guys man
let's let's go
let's go through it joe lead sure let's
go to yasmine she's over in dubai i'm
gonna kind of work
my way i'm the first one okay
hi gary what's up all good
so um i'm an entrepreneur i
have a business in switzerland and
zurich that's a salon
we specialize in eyebrows and i'm
currently here in dubai building the
second salon
and um it's been a challenge but
i am doing it because because because of
kovit
yes of course of course yes um it's been
it's postponed for so long and
um i had a lot of fears and all that
stuff but i'm doing it anyways because
this will stop at one point so um
yeah and dubai is looking very well in
terms of
um 2021 the expo and everything so it
will be a boom
at one point and that's what i'm
currently doing
but in the covid time um
my e-commerce site was built because i
realized okay
um if i don't have um services i'm
making
minus not just zero correct so i built
up an e-commerce store
and with brow products and
it's it's been amazing people were going
crazy over it we made
um like 20 20k
from launching um just for a few days
just
just to test it and it was it was quite
good and now i'm working
on that and um my
um should i go with the question no i'm
going to get context and then we'll go
back a question okay so thank you
okay great thank you go ahead over to
uh matt henry down under uh the
packaging king of australia matt
say hi to gary g'day gary how's it going
i've never been called that joke so
that's me um so
yeah gary i'm looking after um i'm
essentially
i'm a gm of the business but i'm really
a traditional cmo
so i'm on the exact team um looking
after a team of about 75
and packaging business we do about five
other categories as well but we're most
well-known for packaging and that's the
that's the
leading category um doing about 100 mil
a year in revenue with about 40 000
customers
it's predominantly b to b but it's
shifting super super rapidly to
um you know b to b to c there's some b
to c
as well like it's a hybrid back to to
your point
the the first intro was a perfect
example right
humans are building up companies at
scale
that are going to need packaging and so
those businesses are
emerging quickly it makes a ton of sense
i'm seeing this dynamic with packaging
in the u.s
right yes i mean we've gone from you
know our customers being like coke and
ikea
um to now you know we we now
can build a huge amount of scale with
you know another 30
000 small customers from you know
jewelers by the way
those customers are going to grow in
perpetuity
for sure yeah so that's what we see
that's where that's where the internet's
taking us so
i understand so cool that's the business
so
okay well let's uh pull it back real
pleasure cheers
go to the western side of the united
states and talk to one of my favorite
categories of the automotive category
josh lexis is an auto dealer in the
colorado
area josh gary
you're a mute josh joshua i'm you
brother
rookie mistake no worries gary i
actually met you at agent 2021 a couple
years ago so good to see you again good
to see you um
but yeah i am the par owner in three
automotive
dealerships in den just outside of
denver colorado
and um i mean that's really ultimately
all the context i need but
just to give me a little more fodder
since that was so quick um
what's uh what was your biggest ambition
coming to this like what did you
what do you hope to get out of this yeah
so we've created um a
uh kind of a character that's a
caricature of myself and old school car
dealers that were running
um where i've got this cheesy plaid suit
and it's it so we're
introducing uh you know humor and then
also a lot of like value ads like you
know
how do i change my wiper blades how do i
uh you know why should i lease versus
purchase a lot of value
two of my favorite maneuvers in business
yeah so those are two things that we're
doing right now and i just wanna
you know how can we expand on that we
bought the stores in august
and so we're starting at zero you got it
okay next we're gonna go over to texas
and say hi to sam rodriguez who's in the
financial services business
as an advisor sam say hi to gary hey
gary how's it going man
really well sam uh yes so i am
i'm a financial planner i run a team a
small team of advisors here in north
texas
um and we're i'm really just trying to
take advantage of
of what's going on now and and move
my industry sort of into this new age of
how to reach people
so you're looking to build personal
brand let's say a linkedin strategy to
acquire
clients and have leverage to acquire
even teammates and help your teammates
be better as well
that's exactly right right like i really
want to attract those clients and
and attract advisors that want to help
those clients i understand
keep it going oklahoma just north of him
we've got brad derry who's an agency
owner so
very similar to what you asked back in
2009 gary
they had a bra say hi to gary brad hey
gary yeah
so next month we'll be 10 years old
until
2018 it was really just kind of a paying
side hustle maybe a little more than the
side hustle
uh 2018 we kind of launched off and
became a lot more than a side hustle
what what were you doing
besides that brad uh ministry actually i
was a pastor
it's amazing like almost 10 years yeah
keep going
2018 we launched off and really entered
the home services
niche pretty heavily so we worked mostly
with contractors eight back plumbing
that kind of thing
all across the country yeah know it well
okay great looking forward to your
questions
continue up north and we'll head over to
vance in chicago who's a motivational
speaker
hey what's up what's up man uh good to
see you um
my name is stan i'm here i'm an author
of
this book uh making your season i can't
see myself um
um um so i also
um yeah i'm an author and i studied
um some of the greats and motivational
speaking for general
um napoleon hill and things like that so
i'm upcoming just like you know
trying to get with where you are and i
also wrote a book about you that i want
to share with you today man okay
i can't wait to hear about it you're
just trying to build more brand
to have leverage for speaking and
booking exactly
exactly obviously i'll be very ready for
that
okay and last but not least closer to
home gary over in bk we've got calvin
who you know and have had dinner with in
the past calvin say hi to gary again
hey gary great to meet you again great
to see you again cal what's good
yeah um lots of things
so yeah uh i have a software company
simplero i've had that for 11 years
we've actually talked about it in the
past
um 30 people now and looking to leverage
to build my personal brand
because i want to then expand into some
other i'm i'm passionate about
purpose meaning like knowing who you are
how that fits into your business
relationships health so i'm doing
a meal replacement and um a workout
product and then i have ideas for all
kinds other things ultimately wanting to
be
a special advisor to the president of
the united states at some point in the
future helping bring the country back
together
very cool understood one thing real
quick gary before we go into the second
uh round and go deeper i just wanted to
acknowledge that there are some folks
here that brought their plus ones with
them
i have i'll start off courtney
bridgwater nelson's my newest resident
on the west coast
so if there's any business owners on the
phone that would like to introduce their
plus ones really quick before we go into
the deep dive feel free to do so now
i'll go i brought uh jay croft my
my social media manager social media guy
he's
the one person on team get calvin right
now i have like five six last year but
it didn't quite work out
so we're down to jay one step backwards
is always a good strategy
right and i have danielle here who is in
canada she is my executive assistant and
in charge of hiring and culture amazing
i almost forgot to mention my mind to be
here thanks jen i appreciate it brother
thanks for the love
i saw you take the the photo and i was
fired up i'm always flattered by that
[ __ ]
i also forgot to mention we do have kate
from our uh tennessee yes i saw i saw
the name i wasn't sure if she was
running around the house or why she's
not showing um
her video but i was there you are kate
cool so let's go back around in that
james orsini is here
all right cool let's uh get back there
let's uh let's go back around the horn
same pattern this way we can go quickly
so starting with yasmine over in dubai
yes mean uh what do you want to talk to
gary about today
um okay um so
what what came clear to me today is the
personal brand
um my fear there was which i asked the
question already my fear was okay
if i build a personal brand that is so
um attached to my business
how do i exit with it being emotionally
attached to me is it then um
you're not you'll be you'll be stuck
working for your new company
that bought you for three years and
after that you'll be free as a bird and
you'll do it again
oh okay okay no but that i i've asked
that question and now
but it's a very it's a very yeah it's a
very interesting question i'm glad you
asked it
a lot of people fear it so it stops them
from building a personal brand
which often times not always often
is the biggest leverage point you have
to building a big business
but look at the history of time but even
closer to your world
bobby brown the incredible makeup artist
she sold her company
she worked for revlon or l'oreal or
estee lauder i don't remember which big
company bought her
for several years non-compete and then
she was done i'm currently living this
right now i started a wine brand
i sold it to consolation in march i'm
tied up for
another three years and then after three
years i'm going to start a
tequila brand or another wine brand or
what if or nothing
so i i think you need that that was my
biggest fear that was my biggest fear
and i think i i've looked at it in the
wrong perspective correct
but my my biggest my biggest question
for you
is um in if you would be in my shoes
right now building
um two different businesses they feel
like two different businesses although
the same brand right
um how what would your what would your
strategy be there
if you were me i would think about the
world
in a 60 20 20 realm
60 20 20. all of my behavior
the way i would staff my brain my heart
the way i would think about the world
would be 60 20 20. let me explain
60 of my energy time money
would be around the brand because to
your point it's the same brand
two different functions yes 20 of my
heart my soul my money my energy
would be for the unique individual
businesses
to stand up their needs so obviously
the salon that people come to okay what
do you mean with that
you've got correct me from wrong you've
got the salon and then you're selling
the product direct to consumer
yes yes so spending time to hire a
manager for the salon
thinking about the aesthetics of the
salon renovating
the salon changing the prices of how
much you charge at the salon
that gets 20 of my energy
it really gets 80 it really gets 80
because the 60
up top is i'm always thinking about my
business and my brand
yeah same on the other side
having a meeting around cardboard with
mat or packaging
is not something the salon needs but
it's something your dpc business does
what i'm giving you as a triangle to
think about your day
why that works is then you don't get too
far away from one side or the other
because you've got to carry both balls
understand so that's how i would think
about it
they're different businesses but they're
all one business
yeah make sure you it's like having two
children
yeah yeah it feels that way yeah right
but they're both
your family they're both your children
you're gonna care equally
and and passionately and and like if
anybody you know some of the people here
are further along in their parenting
lives sometimes one child needs a lot
more attention for 36 months
than another one for a week and so
being mentally prepared to bounce
between where you need to be
is important but i think what you have
is exactly
right i think you've structured it
properly i think
in today's world having a dtc and a
physical component is a very smart
strategy i
for example as you've been noticing i've
been sipping on something
this is called bone broth i am obsessed
with it
i am seriously thinking about not
kidding getting into the bone broth
business
and when i think about it i think about
having
a incredible beautiful location
one in new york one in la one in austin
one in miami one in chicago
right one in denver and then a very
aggressive refrigerated direct to
consumer
business so you know i think you do both
in today's world of internet and real
life you should be in both
if you're capable some people are not
but i like
i like the way you're going about it
that's a great that's great
what would you say if you say let's
let's say 2060
is brand energy and 20 into the the
salons right
and what 60 brand is really 80
to the salon because the 60 is really
for both
you know just break always think about
brand you know
when i say 60 it's kind of like the 60
is then being deployed against the salon
the 60s deployed against the the direct
consumer business and both are getting
20
of their unabated time so really you're
doing 80 and 80.
so it's not like you're just sitting
thinking about brand every day you're
either in one side or the other
operating your business and probably
every day
a little bit of both just like me yeah
sometimes i'm in vaynermedia right now
i'm spending an hour and a half on sasha
group
i have a very capable leader in james
and he has a very capable team around
him as you can tell
so i don't have to spend a lot of time
on it
you know this is mainly a company
sasha's basically a whole bunch of og's
kate's been with
us for six or five at this point or four
right kate like
this is an og team mainly because i'm
scared
shitless for small businesses to lose
because a big company losing a million
is very five and a half thanks kate is
very very very by the way i'm pretty
proud of myself of saying six and five
per
first which pretty much nailed it so i'm
just saying that's an example of being
in your business the fact
i have 1500 or 1200 employees but i
really did guess six and five for kate
and it ends up being five and a half
that means you're in your business but
you know how to scale
i i know how long kate's been here i
know
about her but i don't need to speak to
her every day and especially because
she's at five and a half year mark
i i know what the conversations we had
in the first year
when in in you know in chattanooga i
also know who's
around in this company it's mainly og's
that allows me not to spend as much time
you might move from 60 20 20
to 65 and 40 and 35 excuse me
because you know the person running your
dtc is perfect you got the system
you don't have to put your energy there
but the salon your best person left
and you've got it and so you're always
moving but that's the way you think
about it um
in in terms of uh marketing like right
now
i have um somebody that's going to do
my ads the number one thing i want to
tell you because i'm in the dubai market
i have multiple people in dubai right
now we're doing a lot more stuff in
dubai
you have to get serious about tick tock
yesterday
yes i wrote that down yesterday
like starting tomorrow three posts a day
on tick tock
starting tomorrow if you can yeah
we'll do that and the paid person
make 80 of the energy show you that
they're getting sales on dtc and getting
registration
at the salon and 20 just attention for
the overall brand
so can you repeat that i can when you
give her or him the job
and you give that say look show me each
month or each quarter or however you do
it
that the money we spent led to a sale on
the
com or a reservation at the salon
for eight out of eighty cents out of
every dollar i give you so if i give you
a hundred thousand dollars
show me with the eighty thousand dollars
that it drove business
the other 20 000 you can spend on
building up the brand
okay cool no i got it thanks gary you
got it joe
uh we're gonna switch gears go and talk
about cars uh let's talk to josh over in
colorado josh let's uh
really intrigued by the the alter ego
you've created let's uh let's get into
it
yeah so we start so we bought the
dealerships august 3rd um
this is all i've ever done is automotive
so it's uh it's definitely you've never
owned dealerships before or you have
i have so i was a partner with elway in
a chevrolet store i took a couple years
off did some uh
consulting and then i got you back yeah
it's in my blood can't get out
so we created this alter ego like i said
his name is chuck cheetham
and he has this nasty i'm so pumped josh
this is brilliant you know that right
yeah so he's got this nasty suit that
ironically i found on etsy and fits me
like a glove
gold chain and i put a wig on so i've
got this great hair
have you created the cartoon version yet
no
okay that's the number one thing you
need to do writing that down
um you need to immediately
whether you hit up james because i know
we have some good illustrative
capabilities
whether you have a cousin who does it
whether you get somebody to do it for
free at the university of colorado
you immediately and i mean immediately
start focusing on the transition
of you yeah you need to build ronald
mcdonald you're more than welcome to be
ronald mcdonald when you go to the
children's hospital you can be in the
commercials
but i need you to build the cartoon
animated version immediately because it
will change your life
you will tell this story of this exact
moment for the next 50 years of your
life and i'm happy because it's going to
build my brand
i'm telling you it's going to work yeah
i love it that's
as soon as we get off the because then
what happens you know what happens then
right
scale yeah yeah yeah it's not you this
guy's on tick tock and instagram and
youtube
every day yeah
yeah and i love you occasionally showing
up as if
yeah so yeah again you could be in the
commercial you could be the non-profit
you could be
you know finally covets over like you
know i actually have a big idea for you
i think you play up a whole story line
of how pissed you are about coven and
how you miss people
so that in 10 months you have like the
craziest
[ __ ] little like fair gathering
farmers market in your locations
i like that you play up this whole thing
that i'm a social animal this [ __ ]
sucks
and then kind of by august as we get
into q4 and everyone's going to get back
to normal
you can then have permission to say as
you know i've been pissed this whole
time caught
up to celebrate we're throwing a party
i'll be at this location from nine to
eleven i'll be at this location from one
to
two thirty and this one from four to
five but we'll have pony rides and
[ __ ] this and that and it will work
yeah local marketing yeah and our
community loves us because one thing
i mean we're deeply involved in the
community we're on all the facebook
groups i mean example is uh we had a
lady who posted on you know the local
neighborhood group
her son's car got keyed and so we picked
her son's car up had it buffed out
dropped it back off so
we do stuff like that you can imagine
this is why i always advocate for
mascots
you doing that is lovely the character
doing that
is game changing yeah yeah love it okay
right
you doing it as a business owner me
doing as a business owner that's a nice
to have it's a nice little story
you and full guard doing it and filming
it and putting it out
gets picked up by the local news and
becomes a thing
yeah that's actually that's a great
point thank you that's a great point
josh this team doesn't keep me around
for my looks
[Laughter]
what uh what con what um what platforms
would you focus on as a cardio tick tock
yeah we've just kind of dipped our toe
in there let me tell you everybody while
i'm just saying tick tock over and over
for all of you i mean
vance it's the most important place for
you it's free organic reach
i don't know what else to tell you you
post something and 80
000 people might see it yeah when you
have four followers
but then how do i monetize how do i then
turn because obviously you can get
what's that brand you don't brand brand
how do you monetize when you do a
commercial
you don't monetize directly in the
commercial they become aware of you and
they come to you yeah
somebody sees the [ __ ] thing they
think it's cool they're 17 they tell
their mom they want to buy from you
they click the [ __ ] lick on tick tock
and you [ __ ] sell a car
yeah love it josh everyone's
transactional especially car
sales and it's it's all [ __ ] brand
you
intuitively are evolving which is why
you created this character brilliant
i love that you asked me that question
like and this is what always happens
yeah i hear it all the time because it's
a new thing i'm like how do you monetize
an outdoor billboard ray katina
has eight trillion [ __ ] billboards j
when james and i go home
i spoke to him years ago he's like how
do i monetize this social media [ __ ]
i'm like
do you think people climb up the pole to
your
[ __ ] billboard press it and buy a car
you're building awareness
yeah oh by the way on the record
tick tock is more likely for you to be
transactional than a billboard a radio
at a newspaper or tv
because when they laugh at your video
they click your profile
click the url in the profile and land on
your website and can
go to a landing page like we just talked
about right
um and and act with matt and actually
the landing page might be uh
set up an appointment if you're under 21
for deep consultation so you don't get
[ __ ]
yeah maybe your whole spiel and tick
tock is every 21 year old
and under you know 16 to 20 year old
gets [ __ ] i'm here to protect you from
all these [ __ ] [ __ ]
and like now you're doing consultation
like it's a [ __ ] hole
oh that's got legs real legs yeah yeah
uh another question for you i i and i i
debate about this with our
with our current agency and that's sem
spend
versus just purely going ott facebook
social you know that sort of thing
because
sem is good because it's expensive
well right it's expensive and you're
paying for something a lot of times you
would have gotten anyway
that's what i yeah and i'm competing
with obviously all the other car dealers
but also the manufacturer to do it right
you're also getting your own you're
paying a toll booth for your own
business
yeah yeah ask ask your team at your
agency
how many of the click-throughs are
directly your brand
and they're going to tell you [ __ ]
that google sells which is you got to
play defense you don't want somebody
else to have it
yeah that's [ __ ] horseshit so what
i've been telling them recently is i
think i just want to get out of sem and
put all that spend we spend
i don't know 40 50 grand a month in
social and
take that 20 30 grand i'm spending an
sem and shift it all back to ott
social media
when i hear that you have such a good
percentage of social to sem i'm excited
i want your sem to be
stronger so that you're just getting
intent
of what you really want okay your spread
doesn't scare me i'm actually proud of
you that's quite progressive
are you feeling good about your social
that's a lot of money to be spending on
social
i'm feeling really good about it yeah
good for you now is that mainly being
spent on media or is that spent on the
creative
organic what is that being spent on 100
media i've got a
social media manager in-house and a
videographer so we don't none of that's
outsourced
so honestly one thing you should think
about is talk to jake once a year
this is why we built it i think james
again
i don't wanna i don't know if it's a
fifteen thousand dollar white board yeah
exactly james
like josh once a year either
watch my content or ping me and i'll
answer something for you for free for
five minutes or
james are you still like 25k on that
thing
yeah it depends on the number of
platforms in the spend it's between 15
and 25.
even better if you're mainly facebooking
and whatever if it's
i can promise you because we're killing
this product and sasha and it doesn't
have to be with us it could be with
somebody else
in-house teams are never going to be as
good as the best of the best
the 15 you spend on education on the
current year's best practices
you're going to spend on waste in media
when you're spending 500 000 a year in
two seconds
yeah find a solution for that okay
that you have to put your contact in
there
gosh i can help you out okay and josh
what makes me comfortable and i'm pretty
not transactional what makes me even
comfortable saying that is what i know
is that joe
they'll tell you not to do it like like
we'll tell you not to buy us
if we like listen for the first 20
minutes and feel like you're close
enough
yeah what we found though is there's a
big delta because a we're the best in
the world at it
and b internal teams tend to not be
capable of keeping up with what's going
on because they're not an agency looking
at everything looking at every business
right yeah yeah well my internal team's
just creative
just the the video and and you know the
organic posts that sort of thing our
agency does the
paid stuff you should bring the paid
internal
what's that you should bring the paper
internal anytime you take media and
creative and separate them either with
agencies or internal external
you lose yeah we're not singing the same
song sheet sometimes that's for sure
you never are you definitely aren't in
the mat like you can see the blatant
ones
but if if i told you the difference of
how many cars you would sell
if you had those things aligned versus
separate it's in the hidden truths
you're like pumped about something where
you're getting leads quote unquote
for 230 bucks and you're like pumped
because it works for your business
but in the separation that 230 might be
86.
yeah josh it is one of the things that
they use our mini recon for
oftentimes they'll take it in as a
playbook make their higher
and then execute against the playbook of
them i can tell you right now
best reason you signed up for this is
knowing that you need to take the media
in-house
yeah promise now you can have bad
casting
for sure i'm basically telling you you
need a good quarterback to win football
games
you could draft a bad quarterback it
happens
yes i'm very aware i'm a jets fan you
know so so
anyway i think that um watson we're
trying
cool i'm happy with that roll over to
uh sam in texas sam let's go
so um so first uh nick gave me some
great ideas on on how to
um create content for for a
for uh for a market that that feels
overlooked and mistrustful
of my industry right and so what i
because and that's
you know it's a high trust thing for for
us to help people
and so it's how do we build that trust
nick helped quite a lot with that but
how do i build that audience for people
to
consume that content i'm gonna give you
the best [ __ ] advice ever i'm so
confident about this one
as good as i've felt so far today this
is the one i'm most
confident about and i'm pretty confident
about everything else i've said
here so far you have to start a podcast
and then you have to post produce the
video
of the podcast for linkedin ads so
what's cool about this is you i'm gonna
make assumptions they have a little bit
of a sense of me sam
what you see from me a lot of times is i
don't i'm not an influencer
i'm a businessman who figured out how to
do things that could be recorded
to then be my content right my entire
speaking career which is lucrative
is mainly because i want the content
it's [ __ ] crazy get paid for
something you're gonna do already
no even better i'm getting paid for
something i wouldn't have done otherwise
that is impacting me even more on my
core business yeah
you know [ __ ] crazy that is that's
basically what i want you to do
watch how this works out so you stand up
a financial service or a money
management or whatever you know you
stand up a show
you know dollars and cents with sam
rodriguez right that's the show
now that you have a podcast you'll be
blown away by what i'm about to say
you start cold emailing people on
linkedin to be a guest
that are fancy fancy people
like people that are on cnbc and the
wall street journal
and one out of every 29 of them sam is
going to say yes
because everybody is a publicity [ __ ]
okay
so how do you how do you how do you even
get an audience for your podcast how do
you build that audience
linkedin so this is the next part so you
film the first one with calvin
it's 42 minutes now you have to have the
ability whether you learn this yourself
because it's fun whether you have a
younger sibling whether you hire an
intern who you know
jay is this guy i assume in calvin's
world or or
or he definitely had somebody in his
world do this because he had six i'm
assuming jay handles a lot of those
things now but
you figure out at the lowest possible
cost sam
which starts with you do you watch 20
hours
of youtube videos for free of how to use
adobe
like you know i'm thrilled if you want
you know i'm sure my team will give you
15 minutes for free to like how to stand
up a podcast like give
we probably i probably have an article
on my website right now
that explains it all so you start up the
show
you then have five moments in your
meeting with calvin that were good
points you felt you sounded smart calvin
made a good stop
uh thank you kate there's something
called stork i'm sure kate will tell you
about that so
but by the way and on the record i know
stork is wildly inexpensive as a
newsletter but
still you can definitely find this stuff
for free it might just save you time you
might want to pay 39 that's why people
pay those kind of things right the time
of finding the free
anyway nonetheless you then
cut those five clips and then you post
them with copy
on your linkedin linkedin is the b2b
version of tick tock right now
linkedin and tick tock are the only two
social media platforms
that will give you organic reach on
every post
more than you deserve based on your
behaviors prior to the post
meaning if you're a quote-unquote nobody
meaning you don't even have a tick-tock
or linkedin account
your first post of a 39-second video
or two-minute 19-second video sam of you
and calvin talking
we'll get 3 000 views whereas that same
video on youtube
and instagram facebook and twitter will
get nine
okay and that will become your life and
then you're gonna learn how to spend ad
money
so now you're spending that now you
learned that a video went viral and you
should spend a thousand dollars
against a five mile radius of you of
your
of your house to get local p like so
you got it yeah so how do you move
people from being consumers of your
content to
consumers of your product by the quality
of your content
okay so they'll just they'll just they
will inquire my friend
and then a hundred thousand percent
because you're gonna say
thanks everybody for listening sam
rodriguez and you know
send an email to me if you need me say
i'm at today and things will just start
happening you're in the first episode
you're gonna say here i am
i don't know if you guys know this
character on the internet garyvee told
me to podcast well here i am let me tell
you about myself i grew up here i did
this this is what i do for a living this
is that
you know my ambition is to educate put
some karma on the board
feature some guests that i think deserve
recognition let the chips fall
where they may would i love to be your
person sure
i would not even say that line or say
that line they both work
the end so if i want if i'm trying to
build
say a nationwide team of advisors that
do fantastic work for people how do i
get these people
that are consuming me to want to work
with my team versus me
very very easily you speak to it about
day one like
i don't sell myself at vayner you just
you say it you say you you storytell
you have your team on one of the
episodes and everyone shoots the [ __ ]
okay you just tell people the truth
you know let me i'm gonna role play hey
guys you know
first of all thanks to everybody who's
listening this is now episode 19. this
has been insane
when that guy like i told you garyvee
like when he told me to do this i never
thought
i'd have this many people ready
listening i'm blown away a couple things
i just want to share a lot of you
reaching out to work with me
let me tell you a little bit more about
my actual business i've got a group of
nationwide people i vet them i do this
so mostly they're reaching out like
honestly i'm probably not gonna work
directly with you
you're gonna be working with my team by
the way if you're out there listening
and you think you're great at this i'd
love to have you on my team
so if you email me and say you want to
be part of the team i'm also always
looking for that
um and also by the way if not you know
please sit back and enjoy this free
information i hope it brings you value
or maybe brings an important question
that you can bring to your
financial advisor and i think what's
cool about that sam is you've already
been in this
meeting with me now for 40 minutes you
can see my concern
we have things that i think can help
josh but i don't necessarily want to
sell josh the 15
000 thing either like i don't want to be
transactional
i want to educate of like hey here's
what you need to think about
right in the macro the right thing is
for me to get everybody's media business
that's how we really do business but i'm
not telling josh to hire sasha over who
the [ __ ] he's using
i'm [ __ ] telling him the best advice
would just take this [ __ ] in-house
yeah got it yep yeah perfect thanks
do that cheers awesome keep it moving
you want to be on a podcast
i will be your 55th episode guest if you
get there
five five it's getting down everywhere
love it joe q keep me honest on that
let's go
i'll keep you honest for sure let's go
on up to uh brad in oklahoma
talk of agency life oh hey gary so i
mentioned that we work mostly with home
service companies you know plumbers hvac
contractors
um so i got kind of like a two-part
question what do you think the most
underutilized platforms are for
contractor marketing and then part two
is what do we need to do right now to
make sure they stay relevant in you know
three to five years
um i think the most underused platform
is linkedin
because i think linkedin is acting more
like facebook did five to seven years
ago not only are you getting organic
reach people are open to
all kinds of information on linkedin
this is not just
about you know like for example i'm
actually making a note right now
i've been this has been the back of my
mind forever i have a great kid on my
team
sam doyle at my dad's liquor store give
me one second i'm sorry but i'm being
meta right now
sam to make three minute line
videos for linkedin for blind text
daily anyway boom like i know he's going
to post something about wine
and that's going to lead to sign ups
organically
so linkedin for sure brad by a country
mile
it will lead to business it's got an ad
product where you can target people by
location because most these businesses
are local
it's expensive ads but it's very
relevant like the people see them which
matters you know people like well gary i
can buy these ads for three dollar
cpms i'm like nobody's seeing them
they're banner ads on
homehomehome.com who gives a [ __ ]
right so um relevance
is completely brad based on content
you could get me to stop right now if it
was titled how to build your own home
office during covid
content right the reason i exist
i some of you have followed me for a
long time calvin i know that to be true
i'm very consistent for 12 years i've
been saying the same [ __ ]
the reason i'm worth listening to is i
make it all relevant to the moment
my attention arbitrage content media
humanity way to manage is consistent
my strategies around tik tok versus
linkedin evolve on a day-to-day basis
the slang the creative the ideas i use
evolve every day that's valuable my back
to brad using it
my religion is locked in my day-to-day
practicing of it evolves with the
reality of the situation
yeah content is the answer to everything
all right yesterday we all had a day off
because of the words that man said
seriously think about that
everybody in our country stayed home
yesterday didn't work for the most part
because a marvelous man came along but
many marvelous men and women have
thought
what mlk thought it was his ability to
create content
that enabled that so if you're not
putting in the reps on content you're
basically it doesn't matter what your
strategy is
here's my strategy i'd like to get a
six-pack
here's the strategy of how to do that i
need to eat way leaner
and i need to do a lot more ab exercises
good news i have an incredible strategy
to get a six-pack
now what you got to do it
i'm telling you the answers right now
it's tick tock and linkedin
the question is are you going to put in
the reps
cool awesome thanks you got it brother
cool um motoring along uh let's go to
chicago
vance let's talk to garyvee here v
garyvee so of course you know that
you're the guy
of um posting i just want you to hear
from me
um yeah a couple things i want to talk
to you
in like an interview um type of
consulting type of style
um first off let me say that i know that
your grandfathers your grandfathers
are proud of the businessman that you
have become both of them you know
you're saying that um i admire the way
you wear
your the the the no belt the no belt
style you got is is dope
um and i think something that is very
very important
is um i say in a video with your
personal trainer
um jordan scheidt he says that you like
to work out every day man
he said every day he had to take a break
because you have to work out every day
so uh that's some of the um things that
i want to share
um so i wrote the book about you it's
called how garyvee changed the world
and thank you it's dope it's dope
because you have the world
and then like far as like the states and
stuff like or the continents
you got happiness you got brand you got
patience
you got all the good stuff
thank you sir so and it's hardcover it's
hardcover
uh i was trying to get in touch with you
i seen that you had an event
on december the 9th that got canceled um
i and before i found four of these i was
um i bought a ticket to come to new york
to go to the pizza place that you're
part owners in yeah
yeah i want to go on the offense with
you man um i want to help you
battle jets you know that's my goal um
so so
as we go through that journey i assume
based on the things you brought up
being a paid author where you're not
self-publishing like that
being a speaker that gets 5 10 15 20 25
30 40 000 a gig those are probably the
two things that you're most looking at
in front of you
yeah exactly where are you in
speaking have you you know as i know
this game well
it takes a long time before people get
paid to speak have you had paid speaking
engagements yet
no um i host my own events so that's
something
that's my avenue yeah but since covert
you know i can't but
that's that's what i do yeah it's
interesting
josh asked a question and it's come up
once
other time here the number let me give
you the number one mistake that i see
every day of the week which is
people in personal brand try to transact
way too soon and then the audience
fights them off and they have no
interest
so the thing that you need to figure out
is what do you have to say to the world
and how are you putting out content
on a daily basis across all platforms
that is your number one requirement
and with no mention of buy tickets to my
events no mention to buying books
no mention build community people will
come out to you and say hey i see you
have this community
can you do this for me can you do that
for me you can monetize the b2b
try not to monetize the audience for one
year and put out as much content as
possible
it is the most important thing i can
tell you
okay um so my ask is a little bit deeper
than that so like i said i want to i
want to help you better just i want to
give you a hundred million dollars
towards buying the jets
but i just need one thing from you and
what i would like to ask you
is to when you have an interview to
bring me
with you on an interview i don't know if
we are going to be going back do
are you are your next events are they
going to um happen or do you think
they're going to be posted on
postpone right now my team is
planning for me to be in person for for
starting in september okay so that's
like the uk or something like that i
believe
that might just be randomly booked there
but like like chicago
like texas like anywhere is what we're
planning
obviously none of us on this call have a
clue about what covets evolution is
gonna be
okay um so i would like you to
um i won't help you better just but i
just need one salad from you i only need
one thing
and i would like you to bring me with
you when you do an interview
and i want to be right there with you in
the internet i want to be i want to be
right there with you or interview
and i only want to say 11 words i want
to say this is a good man i wrote a book
about him
make sure you keep listening to him and
my name is chicago motivation
11 words that's all i want to say for 10
events though
for 10 for 10 interviews yeah i got my
own
i got my own confidence
what's going on here you know listen
that over that's one that's one thing
that's one thing but it's just ten times
i understand i understand what you're
saying yeah
listen why don't we start with one and
let me see how i feel about it
obviously you're opening acting me
you're trying to get awareness through
my audience
i understand what you're doing what i'm
trying to think through vance is how do
i bring you more value my intuition is
i'm i i have a couple of ideas with my 1
37 p.m
i've got a couple ideas that will get
you what you're actually looking for
okay look for example i may have you ask
me a couple of questions and reply to
one and split screen it on my instagram
and tag you and that will give you ten
times the awareness
of what you would be doing by physically
going to ten events and saying that on
stage so
let me think okay i'm gonna stay in
touch with joe i'm gonna tag you into my
team and we'll come up with something
we'll give you a little bit of love
somehow we'll figure it out okay okay
cool a couple more things
so i got a couple questions um so do you
know do you know how to use photoshop i
don't want to ask you that
how do you know how to use no you
and one thing that i really like that
you said in one of your videos
is you said that a person can post
content every day and it can never be
tiring
but you said sometimes a person can post
one
one word and it's too much because they
don't have good intent
so i thought that was very important you
know and i believe in advance
i love that so let me tell you this i'm
telling you think
because i i know you what i mean by that
is i've been around i'm an old man now
i got a lot of wisdom for 45 years
all of this and it's been a theme here
today the person that can hold their
breath the longest wins
and so what i would tell you is i'm
really interested by you and i want to
help you i'll tell you why
in one breath you so get what i said
in that content thing you got it yeah on
the flip side
and i get it you get to the moment right
now here we are right you're gonna
[ __ ] fly and buy pizza like here we
are and so in your mind
rightfully so you're like i'm gonna take
my shot
right but the but the balancing act is
on the other side
you know while you were talking like do
i really want to let this dude get that
one
time to do that because everybody wants
that i don't know him
you know in general i'm concerned about
motivational people because i feel like
they're just trying to monetize audience
and not bring value so i'm going through
all this stuff in my head right
but i'm leaning towards intuition and
giving a gift and i'm like i'm gonna
[ __ ] do literally this is what
happened
i'm not kidding i'm just telling you and
i'm like i'm gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] it i'm
gonna do this
and then you said ten times and that
basically is that one word i'm like this
[ __ ] guy
what i want to help you better just
though no
i'm gonna just i don't need your help
you want me to give you
you want me to give you a co-sign to my
audience to stop
to spark your career which by the way is
right
right you know there's nothing there's
nothing you saying on stage
i'm a good man and getting on to my
audience that's doing anything for me to
buy the jets i'm coming out of my
goodness of my heart to give you
exposure
so yes it's gonna help me it's gonna
help me
but in return i'm gonna have businesses
and different things going on
in which i'm gonna come with money as
amazing you know what i'm saying i
appreciate that good news i already have
enough money from people to buy the jets
that to me is not the issue the the the
issue
and the value i want to bring in this
meeting is
i think you're in an interesting spot
where i think i can really help
which excites me i i
you're not going to need garyvee or any
of these books or services of the
motivational speakers of the past if you
hear me and realize
by you honestly with good intent putting
out content every day
on just linkedin and tick tock that
you'll have the leverage
not me that's what i'm trying to get you
to
don't let me be the gatekeeper to your
spring pad you be the [ __ ] person no
i'm not i'm not
i'm not letting you be the gatekeeper
i'm saying it's a lot of motivation
racism speakers that have come
and like tony robbins les brown all
those guys
and you you're the man right now you
know what i'm saying and i'm next i'm
i'm next for real not joking you know
what i mean like i'm next
so i think okay
i'm not you know let me promise you
yeah i'm telling you with my soul
because i love you
i want you to be next and the number one
way you get to be next
is by putting out content every day
specifically on those two platforms i'm
being dead serious with you
okay cool but we'll still do that
co-sign i'm gonna figure out how to do
it for you one time
i appreciate it you got it all right
who's next
you're a mute rookie mistake
calvin in brooklyn uh you are next and
we're gonna have a brooklyn manhattan
show to close us out
in gary's time hello gary
where are you it's so great to see you
again man um
yes so my question's around i have my
sinclair this is my software company
sinclairo
um right now like i said we basically
have no marketing team for either this
offer anything we've just grown through
word of mouth by having a great product
and doing great customer service um
i've tried in the past we have the team
calvin i've had other people on the
marketing team it didn't quite work out
so now it's a reset
what's the what's the big give me one
minute on the learnings of why it did
not work out
or the hypothesis because maybe you
don't know yet yeah the the hypothesis
um i hired people i think just not
not the right people honestly and and
lack of leadership and
and clear strategy for my side but like
i hired people nobody thought to ask
like who's that
who's our avatar guitar he's who's our
target market or like you know basic
things of that nature
so um and i didn't think of it either so
and last last year on team calendar was
like a lot of just bringing a lot of
people on a lot of chaos and
you know i like kias but it didn't work
out with the team
i understand yeah and so
yeah so trying to figure out like i
really what i love doing
is uh live q and a's i freaking love
it bringing people on just answering
their questions helping them with
whatever i don't need
i enjoy it so much i don't need to like
make it transactional anything like that
um so we've been doing uh some of that
and it's
it's great we're not getting a lot of
traction on people actually
viewing the content so trying to figure
out like do i just
do that branding like you said for a
year put out that content and not even
think about monetizing it where are you
are you distributing the content we've
been doing
youtube facebook instagram um
twitter to some extent not linkedin and
not tick tock so that's perfect that
excites you
exactly that excites me right i'm sure
that's in jay's pretty head
and so you'll attack that so to me
the answer is yes but what you can
imagine will make both of you
far more excited is actually seeing it
getting traction
hence strategic organic content
everything's right this is why i'm so
loud y'all
the reason i'm yelling so loud is these
doors close
facebook fan pages were insanity in
2012.
twitter was bonkers in 2009 1011. i
masked a million followers as a liquor
store guy in new jersey
right instagram was crazy in 2014-15
tick tock was crazier a year ago than it
is today already
already get on linkedin
and tick tock organically yesterday but
understand
that the content the slang the written
words the way you do it
need will it will do better if you
understand
the platforms you know when you add six
hat when when sam adds six hashtags
that are financial terms to his little
clip that may make ten
more people discover it you know when
when you lean on jay because he actually
is native to
tick tock because he and or his social
circle lives in it
he's gonna know how to do the sticker
overlays or what a duet is
that [ __ ] matters strategic organic
content
yeah so in terms of of like
they're the sa it feels to me like the
sas business the software company
there's like a lot of practice around
how to market sas and sort of more
uh direct response type of things and
you know the cac and the ltvs and all
like all those kinds of that side of
things and then there's the the content
you got it you got it that's why i won
with empathy
a pure math and art machine by the way
if there was only the content part
i would have never built vaynermedia i
want to build the greatest
math and art cac and ltv machine in the
world
and then you put you know so think of it
like like i want to build the best
batter to make the best cupcake i'll be
the whipped cream the cherry and the
sprinkles
that's what makes the ultimate cupcake
but if you don't have the cupcake part
then you know what ends up happening
people just are sizzle
and they lose
yes now what i've really learned in my
3.0 version
is i'm almost turning the sizzle into a
smart cac and ltv thing
which is the hence team gary and that's
why we're now at this apex
say more about that i used to just make
good videos on youtube and i was [ __ ]
crushing right
now i know how to take that video and
create 31 pieces of creative out of it
it's a podcast
it's an article for my blog it's a
linkedin post
one clip gets 14 million views from you
know it's why dailyvee started right
that's why i started vlogging my life
i'm like oh my god this is the [ __ ]
powder
so i'm pushing sam who's busy doing
another thing to do a podcast
that will be the powder to make all the
other stuff happen it's why i'm so
pumped with you i think q a is the
number one way
to make great post-creative content so
you're because you don't have to think
you're just answering and then
you and jay and whoever else are then
tweaking and
you know yep yeah it's so easy and you
took it one step further gary by
now applying it to your business where
you could take a tweet and make a super
bowl commercial
later down the road yeah i mean to your
point
the pcs the post creative strategist the
person calvin you'll eventually add to
your team
that you and jay or whoever you're
making 39 pieces of content a week
or a day and then somebody's reading
every comment
from that to then inform the next thing
you should do
and to james's point at vaynermedia
we've gotten to a place where a single
tweet
eventually became the seed that created
a super bowl spot right
yeah fantastic so so
is there a way to like how do i best
leverage my software company
into the personal brand like i'm using
that audience for q a
and using it for distribution right is
there is there another way there and
then the next question is
you know leveraging the personal brand
into some of the other products that i
have like
my body meal meal replacement thing and
other things of that nature so i think
you're doing the right thing with the
business then
as far as your other things that's where
jay has to do strategic organic content
aka
all your bios have to be strategic
right so your url for one week
on your biggest platform let's make
pretend for now it's instagram
has a url that links out to the sas
company but wait a minute then you're
like wait a minute
that makes no sense the instagram
audience is much better for meals
so we're gonna put our meal thing oh
we're converting better there right
instagram story swipe ups right
you know and so you're cross-pollinating
it and i mean i always tell people
before you come to this before you work
with sasha or vayner
audit the [ __ ] out of me why do i have
different urls on all my social media
you think i'm doing that for my health i
promise you i'm not you know why do i do
this why do i do that so
keep that in mind as well but it's
pointing people to different places
based on different places you have
attention
got it and once you're split between so
the organic
linkedin tick tock get that but uh where
do you
where does the paid come in when it on
the brand side of things
it depends on the business but tick tock
instagram and facebook are my favorite
paid products
right and you so they are they as well
are they just based on them like is that
just awareness impressions or do you
do you track that to some other metrics
one more time my brother because i was
replying to jay saying that he copied my
bio and i was laughing one more time
sorry uh yeah um so when you do paid
around the brand stuff do you
do you just do that based on you know to
to get impressions and awareness or
yes it's my general fee straight up my
feel
do i think people are seeing this and
now they know who gary vaynerchuk is
and i usually pay against either one of
two things something that went
organically viral
i'm like oh people like this let's pay
or something i really want [ __ ] to
know
nothing in the middle i've never seen
any i see all your organic content all
this
time i never see any characters i'm
spending more and more money on people
on my team
because i'm so good at organic
but i'm not against paid and i'm about
to spend a lot of money on tick tock
because it's so cheap
got it nice oh all right if i have more
time i
i have a much quite different uh
question here so i realized that there's
there's a lot of people that i know that
i could reach out to and and
do like do like clubhouse panels with or
things of that nature or other things
and i just know this like insecurity
that pops up in me all the time i'm like
i don't belong they don't want to hang
out with me they want to want to play
with me and that kind of stuff
and i don't know if you have something
anything to say to that
uh do you remember riding a bike
swimming
or kissing somebody for the first time
or having sex like anything that all of
us have been through this
multiple times growing up had scary ass
[ __ ]
like it was petrified i was petrified
to swim and ride a bike i was petrified
to kiss a girl actually at the same time
that sounds i'm just scared
so like i understand being scared i just
want to remind everybody
you eventually did it and now it sounds
ridiculous of the thought of being
scared of it
what's going to happen they're going to
make you feel bad that you're not
important enough
well you're going to reach out to
garyvee and he's not going to reply and
now you think
[ __ ] you know he doesn't think i'm cool
like who gives a [ __ ] go to the next
person
yeah no you're right 100 have jay do it
right how did you do it right and i'm
like if and by the way that's that's
what you do like i have noticed how i
said i don't do photoshop i paint people
do photoshop i don't like it i don't
know how to do it
all right i have a little bit of
emergency i have to bounce we're good
joe yeah we're good we went through
everybody twice
thanks guys bye everyone thanks gary
enjoy the rest of this
take care youtube watcher what's up it's
garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon